Also, good morning.
Good morning, girl.
I'll have my camera off if that's okay.
Go.
Hey John, good morning.
Hey, good morning, guys. Good day.
How are you doing today?
Hope you guys are having a good one. So far, so good.
Hey, John.
Thanks for asking.
Kaila.
I'm returning from a few days out of office, so just playing catch up.
Okay, okay. It was a holiday or like...
Yeah, it was my daughter's birthday. She's now two years old, so we took some time to celebrate.
Ohh, wow, wow.
Well...
That's sweet.
Great.
Nice. Congratulations.
Reid.
Thank you. Yeah, she's the best thing in my life.
Yeah.
It's what we do it for.
Mhm.
Definitely.
In fact, you can, I don't know if you can see my picture in Teams, my profile picture, or if it just says my initials. Okay.
No, we can't.
Chris probably can since he has a random account. I can't, unfortunately.
You can kind of see her in there.
Feel free to share.
Let me see if I can.
Definitely love Julka.
Yeah, please, that'll be great.
Hey, Allison, good morning.
Good morning.
How's everyone doing?
Been good, can't complain.
What about you?
Not bad.
A little colder than I'd like, but...
Uh-huh.
I have a blanket.
Sure.
Yeah.
So like summer is on or like still you get the glimpse of winter where you are.
Well, so it gets cold. It was about 40 degrees Fahrenheit again last night, which maybe is normal for here. This is my second year living in the States. So I'm in the northern United States now. And
Okay.
Spring and winter are arguing with each other a lot still.
And it got pretty hot yesterday during the day, though.
Sound interesting?
Keith.
And then cold again at night.
Pre.
Hey, Cassie, good morning.
Good morning.
Hi, Cassie.
Morning, guys.
So I'll have my camera off because actually, actually I'm on leave today and just at my relative's place. So you might hear some background noise as well. So I'll keep myself on mute. Kris is going to run the show today, but still, I'll jump in between. I'm still on the call. My ears are here, but yeah, just in case.
I'm gonna keep my camera off too.
Thank you, Keith.
Right.
Thank you.
Go for it, Kris.
Can you hear my screen? Yeah.
Please let me know if you can see my screen.
Yes.
Right there.
All right, thank you everyone for joining the monthly service call for Red Home. Today we are going to discuss about the data for the month of April, starting from 1st of April till 30th of April.
All right.
Going to the next slide, agenda remains the same. Check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
Right, going further towards the data or the numbers, right? I just want to know from you guys, like anything, any insights you want to share, any update regarding the team or the service, anything?
I don't have anything.
I don't think I have anything.
Maybe Kason, you can go ahead.
I said I also don't have anything, nothing specific today.
OK, OK, OK. I thought, like, there is something anyway. Thank you, John, from your side, do you have anything?
Not much, like I said, I'm also playing catch-up, but I think from the last, since the last time we met, things have been pretty steady.
Great, good to hear that. Good to hear that. So, once again, like we are truly committed towards adding value, all right? Anything you find, all right, where we can do better, all right, in terms of adding anything extra towards the service, please let us know how we can improve, all right?
All of the scope of improvement.
All right, going further, this is the highlights for our previous meeting. All right, so performance overview, reviewed utilization and ticket closure across local and enterprise team. Overall performance remains stable. Closure insight, strong performance observed across most engineers.
Thank you.
Improvement focused identified for Kiara, Razdan, and Davis. C set updates scores remain high, out of scope, remote scope responses excluded, operational update processed on SIP review, written board access enabled.
and NOC coverage adjustment implemented. So now NOC team is not there, right? So now we are just discussing on the HD part only. So process focus, reinforce weekly review, QA checks, target.
Targeted training and recognizing on drive consistency coordination, POC rules certified on the improved communication and responses during the outages.
Emphasize on the best practices, such as weekly performance review, QA check-in, checks, training, and recognition initiatives.
So, these are some action items which are remain open from our previous discussion, ready them to review the SIP created based on the recent issues and gaps, which is which we have already shared. Keith, I guess you have already shared it, and second one is regarding the board review.
If we can, if I can get some extra access, right, where I can find out like some better understanding about the tickets, right, regarding first call resolution or maybe resolution time, okay, those kind of things that will definitely give us a better understanding on a day-to-day work.
For the engineers.
These are ITBD recommended KPIs. Billable utilization, 80% billable utilization, which is recommended. Ticket resolved per day, 8 to 10 tickets. CSAT, customer CSAT, and 95% with a response rate of 30%. SLA compliance, 95%.
FTR first touch resolution at 60%, same day resolution at 80%. So this last four numbers we are not able to put up right now due to the access issue, right? If we have the proper access, we would be able to find out more information on those.
Numbers.
So going further, this is the utilization data for the local team. Okay, overall performance for the month of April, the average performance for the team is at 80.7%. Overall team has improved. In the month of March, it was 77%.
If I talk about individual engineers, five out of seven engineers are able to achieve the 80% valuable target. Overall performance reduced from 25 to 22% positive trend. Our top performer, Rajan, he is at 89%, then we have Ishaan.
86 percent, Neo is at 85 percent. Then we have Kaila, she is 81 and Joe is at 82. So if I talk about Kaila and Joe, they have definitely improved their number. If we can see from the month of March, Kiara has improved from 7 percent, she has improved.
from 74 to 81 and Joe, she was at 77, now she's at 82.
Now, there are two team members who are not able to achieve the 80% billable utilization. That is Grace and Kenneth. For Kenneth, we do understand he's at off our shift, though. If I compare this with our previous service call, he has also improved from 61 to 67%.
Grace, she has improved, shown some little bit of improvement from 73 to 75. This is something which I am still working with Grace, all right, just to make sure that she should be all, she should be able to achieve the 80% billable utilization.
Going to the next slide, this is for the enterprise team. Out of four engineers, three of the engineers are able to achieve the 80% believable utilization. Top of the chart is Arvind, he is at 89%. Then we have Shiva, he is at 87%. Then Morris, he is at 85%. Now we have Davis.
If I compare it with our previous data, previous service call data also, he has a dip for one person. I'm closely working with him, okay, just to make sure that he should work on adequate amount of tickets, okay, and make sure he is giving.
or putting the right utilization numbers on them. Anything from your end, John, regarding this?
An input.
No, thank you. I would also be curious if they provided you any feedback about their workload or anything that they're not telling me, but other than that, I have no comments.
Okay.
No, as such, there is no such discussion. All right. However, yes, whenever I had a discussion that there are now they are working on full stream tickets also, specifically Arvind and Davis. Okay. Earlier it was Shiva and Morris who was, these are two engineers who are only working on full stream, but now, yes.
Mm.
For Arvind and Davis, they are working on full stream ticket. The specific kind of tickets they are working on, and definitely it has improved the number for Arvind and for Davis. I'm still working with him just to make sure that he should work or be more focused on picking up tickets and...
more active on resolving those tickets, which will definitely improve his numbers.
Long.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
So this is the ticket closure for the HD local team. The average closure for the team remains at 87%. Top of the chart is Kenneth. He's at 99%. Okay. So if I talk about number of ticket work, Kenneth has worked on 317 tickets out of which he is able to resolve 315 tickets.
Most of them are regarding the security alerts, okay, for email security alerts, which he is working on right now. Then we have Grace, she is at 96 percent, sorry, closure rate. Then we have John, sorry, Joe at 91. Neo is also at 91 percent.
A closure rate showing some strong numbers. Then we have Kiara and Razdan individually. Kiara is at seventy-nine. OK, if I compare this with our previous discussion, she has improved. OK, 9% improvement, I can see, and Rajan also he has shown some significant improvement from sixty-six.
is at 72. Slowly and gradually, these are the two engineers from the local team which we have discussed during our last session also that they need to improve their numbers and they are working on it, but still I see there is scope of improvement which I'm closely working with them just to ensure.
they can cope up with other team members. Anything you want to add, Allison?
Cassie.
Oh.
No, I don't think I have anything.
Yeah, I don't have anything more.
All right, so yes, as a team, team has worked on.
Yeah.
1,366 ticket and they are successfully able to close 1,211 tickets.
Now, if we talk about the Enterprise team, Enterprise team has shown some very good numbers. Three of the engineers are above 90, okay, where Morris is topping the chart with 98% closure, where he has worked on 397 ticket out of which he is able to resolve 392.
Then we have Irwin. He is at a 98% closure, where he has worked on 128 tickets, out of which 126 got closed. And Shiva, he has closed 369 tickets out of 382 with the average closure of 96%.
Davis, once again, closure percentage remains at 77 percent, but yes, we can see some significant improvement if I compare it with our data for the month of March.
As a team, team has worked on 1053 ticket out of which they have successfully closed 1000 tickets.
Yeah.
Going further, this is the CSAT report for the month of April. Okay, so altogether, a team has received 72 surveys, out of which 57 are excellent and nine of them are good.
So if I talk about okay and poor, there are five surveys which are marked as poor and one for Kiara, which is marked as okay.
So when last time I had a discussion with Cassie, she informed me that for Neo and for Razdan, we can wave off because Neo has received 2 poor surveys, those can be removed or revoked. And for Razdan also, one poor survey can be removed. So that means.
Out of 10, we have 7 engineers who have achieved 100% CSAT. Okay, then we have 3 tickets, one for Kiara, as I said, she has received an OK survey. Then we have for Shiva, that is regarding a ticket for Mac issue.
Though I am able, I have already shared a document or detailed report regarding the ticket. When I am not able to find out any loophole, it may be like customer has misjudged the ticket or something like that. I'm not sure. They have marked it as poor. For Morris also, there is one ticket that is 544.
three to five. Okay, I specifically checked on the ticket. Seems like he has mentioned everything. It was out of scope issue. Okay, well he has mentioned that what are the steps needs to be get done. The ticket was about getting a co-pilot business license access for full stream. This ticket was for full stream client.
So he has mentioned that he needs to get guided the user how to get the access from Jira. OK, but seems like a user had still given a desat to Morris.
Mhm.
Yes. So unfortunately, we do see that with Full Steam specifically. Users don't like their corporate approval process, which is not something that's in our control. It's not something in Morris's control. We do communicate that back when we receive our feedback tickets when that happens.
Go home.
Yeah.
Right.
Oftentimes, the end user does not respond to us. They don't, they're not interested. They're just upset that they didn't get that instant gratification. So while I don't have a way to actually remove that out of the system, I can consider that.
Mhm.
Ohh.
Right, right.
Mm-hmm.
in my own reporting, so I don't count that against him.
Show, show.
or anyone else that that happens to.
Sure. So once again, Allison, regarding Shiva's ticket also, I will ping you the ticket number, okay? Please, I request you please review the ticket because I don't see any problem. He has responded to the user on the rightly manner. He was able to provide this resolution. Everything was on time, okay?
Sure.
Yeah.
There is no issue with the response or anything. But yes, user has mentioned a DSAT. So please review the ticket in case if there is a scope or something. Okay. Regarding Chiara, no, I haven't sent that to you, though I will mention it on the email, which I'm going to send after the meeting. Okay. Or maybe I can ping you on the chat.
OK, sure.
Have you already sent that to me?
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
The teams check.
Oh, whichever you prefer, that's fine.
Sure. And regarding Kiara, okay, I have already shared the feedback with Kiara. It was regarding a black screen issue. Though she has done the correct troubleshooting, she was able to resolve the issue, but it seems like she could be more proactive in terms of responding to the email because I can see there's a gap.
in terms of responding back to the email or giving a proper response to the client. So I have already shared the feedback with Kaila and she has already acknowledged that and she is going to work on that.
Rick.
All right.
So, that's it for...
Service part, now this is the SLA compliance, which I which we can remove.
Okay, so this is a way forward for the team. All right, like the best practices, weekly performance assessments to assess engineers technical strength and identify the training needs, regular ticket board reviews to ensure progress, quality, and adherence to the SLA expectations, enhanced QA process, Pre escalation review of tickets to reduce.
unnecessary escalation, weekly QA checking, checks on the escalated ticket types to improve the service quality and trend analysis, control leave planning with the requested request expected at least two weeks in advance to maintain the consistent coverage.
recognizing recognition of team achievement and key customers satisfaction milestone to drive moral and continuous improvement, internal level of training sessions to help engineers burden to their skills and skill sets and increase the value to deliver to the team.
to the account. So regarding this Intel training, I would like to inform you that Ishan is going through with the training right now, okay? He's appearing for the next level, okay? Internally for ITBD, he is appearing for Advanced System Administrator. So let's see, okay, if we have any update, we'll definitely share with you.
Rick.
All right, this is AI by Design, our internal program which we have already discussed and this is the recap which I'll share after the meeting and team GPS. Team GPS, we have already discussed about the internal, our in-house program. Okay, my application where it is very useful. So our consent team is already working on get in touch with.
with the team for Rhythm. And that's it.
In terms of slide, now I would say it's an open house.
Haley.
So, an open house now, so I'll just go one by one. Allison, would you like to add something?
I don't think I have anything, no. Thank you, Kris.
No.
My only note is, sorry, Javid. My only note is just a reminder across the board for everybody and I don't have the holiday list in front of me, but May 25th is the holiday for all of us. So we won't need coverage that day. It's very possible that's on your lists. I just don't have it in front of me.
Right.
Okay, so if I understand you correctly on 25th, like random operations remains close, right? And there will be no coverage from ITBD side.
That is correct.
Okay, okay.
At least for our purposes, I can't speak to the other departments who might use you.
Okay, sure.
John, anything from your end?
I don't believe I have anything. No, I did note that my name was listed as the action item for getting you access to some boards. And I do believe we talked about that before. I'll follow up again internally. I think Chris, you do have some access. At the time we were talking about getting it for Keith.
Hello.
And I've passed that up the chain as far as I can go. So I'll try again, but I don't know that there's anything I can do. Just wanted to remind you.
Yep, so I won't be needing the access, John. It's just Kris. Kris has the Redm account created for himself. Just maybe a few other accesses, like access to the phone tool where he could check the queue and make sure, you know, the engineers are on avail or making sure that they are logged in and, you know, available for the calls, incoming calls.
Go.
Was monitoring the queue regularly, like I said, so currently he just has the access to the the PSA tool, yes, and and the reports that were shared with us, but yeah, if there's any other access that you can link that thing that he it can help us with the day-to-day operations when it comes to the Helpdesk piece, then it would be it would be great.
Support.
Okay, so I'm understanding it's you're just asking for any and all access you can get in specific the phone tool.
Correct. Yep.
Okay, I understand. I'll ask again with my leadership to see if there's anything else we can give to you that we haven't already. I think that's a good idea.
Sure.
Ohh.
Perfect. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
Lee.
Yeah, hey everybody. Yeah, I know. John, Allison, Cassie, good to see you all. Just jumping on, say hi. Keep an ear to the ground, it sounds like, sounds like a couple things are to be addressed, but Kris and Keith are on top of all. So.
Like to add something?
Allaine.
Sunny.
Hey, Natalie, good morning.
Hey, good morning, Kris.
Would you like to add something?
I don't have anything, anything else from my side either. So I did run into John a couple weeks ago at Enable, but that was about, that's all I have really.
Right.
Yeah, I think he mentioned that.
Okay, so I think that's it. Once again, thank you everyone for joining the service call. And I'm going to share the MOM for the meeting along with the slides, which we have discussed. And thank you.
See you next time.
Thank you for your time. Take care.
Thank you. Bye.
Thank you, everyone.
Thanks, everyone.
Yes.